[Musik]
moloch berlin
wie in vielen großstädten des westens
sind harte drogen ein großes problem
abhängige leben nur für die nächste
dosis sie treffen sich im untergrund in
u-bahnhöfen wir durften verdeckte
ermittler bei ihrer arbeit in den
bahnhöfen begleiten das ist ein klaren
bei den tony machen
carolin diel also meistens die 17 16
manchmal sind die auch erst 13 oder so
hauptsache von der familie damit sie
wenn sie erwischt werden nicht einfach
den chef ausliefern der ja gleichzeitig
ein großer bruder oder onkel ist die
gehen zur arbeit wie andere leute ins
büro er hat keine angst vor dem knast
und wenn er doch mal rein muss sagt dass
ich ich habe schon 200.000 300.000 euro
gemacht wenn er zum beispiel in
frankreich als tourist landet kommt er
von dort aus illegal nach deutschland so
dass deutschland gar nicht weiß woher
kommt er kommt mit leeren händen
versteckt sein ausweis seine dokumente
und sagte seit palästinenser
ihre drogenprobleme in den griff
[Musik]